welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host Paul and this video are
breaking down house of the Dragon season
2 there's just been a big panel at
ComiCon XP and along with this we also
got our first look at the brand new
season throughout this video we're going
to be breaking down what could be
happening in the show and also
discussing where we think things will go
heavy spoilers ahead and we will touch
upon some major things in the book so if
you don't want to know then turn off now
if you want a more spoiler filed video
then make sure you check out our blood
and cheese breakdown for what's going to
be something that's definitely going to
break the internet better than Allison's
feet those lovely lovely feet anyway
without the way let's get into house of
the Dragon season
2 errors were made in the hours
following King maser's
death the wall
be many will die
and the Victor will eventually Ascend
the
throne there is no war so hateful to the
gods there's a war between
[Music]
Ken and no war so bloody as a war
between now the main thrust of season 2
is going to be the dance of the dragons
in which we pick up in the aftermath of
season 1 we close things out with First
Blood being drawn and that's then going
to take us in the Sun for a sun chapter
that's actually going to be the title of
episode two which we'll see rira being
out for vengeance aan of course ended up
killing lucaris but the book played
things out slightly differently in that
aan didn't regret it or that's at least
what we heard from the secondhand
accounts they also had one person
believing that lucaris fell into the
water below and and woke up carrying
Amnesia this said that said that he went
on to live a peaceful and happy life
unaware of what happened and and that's
how that's how I like to think of
him oh either way this was a big fa p as
one isn't allowed to kill an Envoy thus
this breaks Royal protocol which along
with all the other really pisses
rira off sounds so Regal saying one and
Royal protocol but in the aftermath of
this aan gets the nickname which has
being known as the kinslayer originally
in the book Damon was away at Haron Hall
which is when he s a raven saying her
son would be Avenged in the show though
Damon's going to be there with her so
they're kind of just making some more
economic storytelling now during this
Damon reached out to myara and asked for
her to hire two assassins this is where
the sun for sun title comes from and she
hired two of the biggest scumbags in all
of King's Landing that is none other
than blood and cheese who infiltrated
the red keep through the Forgotten
passageways I'm pretty sure they'll use
the one rer use to sneak out of in
episode four and then it'll kind of
bring things full circle from that the
pair were instructed to kill one of Egon
sons and what happens next I ain't got
the heart to tell you mate but let's
just say Tiny Tim you won't be coming
home for Christmas now it's really
messed up with this being something
that's going to shatter the foundations
of the show a couple of months back we
saw there was footage from the set that
showed a funeral procession building off
the back of what happens in this moment
again that's something that we've
already broken down so if you if you
desperate to know what happens then make
sure you check that video out now cheese
managed to escape but blood himself was
then caught and tortured he was also
found carrying the victim's head which
I'm guessing will be a big point in the
series now another thing that we know
will be happening in the show is the
battle between the two twins that is
Eric and aric Carill who it's been
leaked will fight in episode two whether
that's the case or not we don't know but
that's a report that's coming in from
the Twitter account called wake the
Dragon the twins were two characters
that demonstrated how divisive that the
conf conflict was with it literally
turning brother against brother that's
some it's of course used to describe a
Civil War and here we're going to see
the pairs fight playing out both of them
have their own separate allegiances with
Eric even stealing the crown so he could
give it to rira it all went down in
episode 10 with aric still remaining
loyal to King Egon now if you want to
show who your allegiances lie with then
definitely check out on merch store
below we've got two T-shirts that you
can pick up with either a green or black
design on the front of it this will let
you show which team you rock with and
might even get you into your own bloody
Civil War he against you mate you know
the one loves a bit of egg on his face
not like that mate anyway it all goes
towards helping videos like this get
made and we greatly appreciate the
support shabow what happens is that aric
sent to Dragon Stone under the orders of
Grandmaster Orwell now the book then
says the true purpose of Sir aric's
Mission remains a matter of some
contention Grandmaster monin tells us
that Caril had been commanded to slay
rira putting an end to her Rebellion at
a stroke whilst mushroom and sis Sons
were kill's prey that egg on the second
wish to wash out the blood of his mured
sons with that of the bastard nephews
jeris and Joffrey strong Sara came
ashore without hindrance stuned his
armor and white cloak and had no trouble
gaining entrance to the castle in the
guise of his twin brother just as
Christen Cole had planned deep in the
heart of dragon Stone however as he was
making his way to the Royal Apartments
the gods brought him face to face with
Sir Eric himself who knew at once what
his brother's presence meant the singer
tells that Eric said I love you brother
as he unhe his blade and that Eric
replied and I you brother as he drew his
own now from this point the pair jig out
and Yeah promise no spoilers on any
deaths still though it's going to lead
to a big battle but it completely pales
in comparison to what comes next that is
something that sees the dance of the
dragons and that's going to heavily
Focus around the queen Who Never Was AKA
rise she already proper messed up the
king's coronation like Camila shoted and
that new bit for the show clearly
spelled out the wedge that was going to
be built between them Reise is a big
member of the black Council and she and
her Dragon mise fight at something known
at the Battle of ruk's rest attacking
Christen Cole that that little piece of
she's then met with eggon and aan
riding Sunfire and bagar so far Sunfire
he hasn't been a big player in the show
yet and they actually kept him out of
the king's coronation that had egg on
mounting the Beast and riding around
while waving at the crowd it was done as
a terrifying display of dominance that
was meant to show how powerful that the
King was in the show though it was of
course interrupted by Rise And Thus
they've been saving until this point to
show how big sunfire's gotten it's going
to lead to a massive battle and
sunfire's dominance has been hinted at
in the new logo we can see the
three-headed sigil which has now been
updated to be golden like the dragon
either way M finds it really difficult
going against them but she does actually
manage to get a couple of big licks in
this includes burning the crap out of
Egon who's beat how badly his armor
actually melts into his body man is
pretty much left at death store and this
Aon ends up taking charge for a bit
that's something I can see happening at
the midpoint of the Season which is then
probably going to take place over a
couple of different episodes either way
it becomes clear that the dragons are
what's going to win this without taking
us in the next point I want to talk
about it turns out that when the
targaryens were on Dragon Stone they
used to frequent The Villages below this
this had them getting drunk you know you
know the lads night out and they knocked
up some of the women and this has led to
a number of different bastards now the
targaryens they're all about positive PR
and they want to keep up the illusion
that you have to be one of them to ride
a dragon this will mean that the
peasants don't rise up against them and
instead view them as being almost like
Gods obviously some of the targaryens
also believe that they're the only ones
who can ride dragons as well and thus
they end up looking for the bastards now
these characters they're all known as
the dragon seeds and they come from the
islands of blackwat bay the blacks go
down there and order to get them and
because they carry targaryan blood they
can become Dragon Riders now this won't
break the technicality of them needing
to be from the blood of the dragon and
thus the legend can be retained again I
think the targaryens they probably
believe they're the only ones who can
ride them which is why I think they go
specifically looking for these people
now amongst them are some big characters
in both Hugh hammer and nettles early
rumors about the show said that Nettles
wouldn't be in it which had many people
thinking she'd be safe for season 3
because of this don't know how deep into
the dragon seeds will get and
potentially they'll save that until the
end of the season I can see something in
my head where they end with a big loss
and then the blacks are going to be like
we have to get more as we know Season 2
is only eight episodes and we are losing
two hours of what was in season 1 now
that could then lead to them mouning up
for season 3 and leading to the many big
dragon battles that we get in the work
however that report might have been a
load of rubbish cuz we did get some
images that look like the pair but these
two photos are alongside how their
characters have been shown in the
artwork and you can you can see the
similarity so yeah that's why I'm kind
of doubting it I think it would be great
to have the pair popping up and yeah let
me know below if you think it's them
either way we also have the targarian
kids still left who also have some big
moments that happened as well season one
ended with Jace flying off and you're
probably wondering what's happened to
this very strong boy he's very very
strong isn't he very strong
boy anyway Jace was on a similar mission
to his brother Luke and he ended up
flying Vermax out of the area where he
met Lady Jane Aaron there were rumors
that jaay had to sleep with her to get
her to do it but these came from the
gossip mushroom who so far hasn't
featured in the show he's actually quite
a big part of the book and it seems like
they're just completely skipping over
him now Jason went out to White Harper
and promised Joffrey's hand in marriage
and this was all before he headed out to
Winterfell this is where he became good
mates with Lord craen Stark and also met
the character Sarah snow according to
the rumors he married her in secret
though they did discount in the book
that this ever happened still though I
think the show is going that way and
these stops could all be something
that's lited throughout the season now
speaking of litter Vermax apparently
laid a litter of eggs at Winterfell
which could be something that ends up
happening in the show they're clearly
going to need to get more dragons in
though and yeah I'm very excited to see
where it
[Music]
goes
either way mate there's your bloody
breakdown and I hope you've enjoyed us
going through it all obviously I'd love
to your thought as well so make sure you
drop them in the comments below please
hit the thumbs up you son of a and
if you want to support the channel as a
member of the spoiler Society then
please click the join button you'll get
early access to videos every week and it
goes such a long way to helping us out
we've also got the t-shirts that we
mentioned before and yeah huge thank you
for all you guys support now if you want
some else to watch you've got that blood
and cheese video on screen right now so
yeah go head over there if you really
want to spoil it I know you do I know
you do you're thinking about it should
have should have ruined it for myself
and yeah definitely head over there
right after this cor and now without the
way huge thank you for sing through the
video I've been your host Paul and I'll
see you next time take care
peace